how do you imagine the life of a
scientist boring and monotonous spending
endless hours in the lab with no social
interaction maybe for some but not Tycho
Brahe hey the 16th century scholar who
accurately predicted planetary motion
and catalogued hundreds of stars before
the telescope had been invented also had
a cosmic sized personal life Tycho Brahe
he was born in 1546 to Danish Nobles but
at age two was kidnapped to be raised by
his uncle instead his parents didn't
seem to mind Tycho was supposed to have
a career in law but after witnessing a
solar eclipse at 13 he began spending
more time with mathematics and science
professors who taught him the art of
celestial observation by the time Tico's
uncle sent him off to Germany a few
years later he had lost interest in his
law studies instead reading astronomy
books improving his instruments and
taking careful notes of the night skies
it wasn't long before his own
measurements were more accurate than
those in his books while in Germany
Tycho got into a bit of an argument with
another student at a party over a
mathematical formula resulting in a
sword duel and Tycho losing a good sized
chunk of his nose after that he was said
to have worn a realistic prosthetic of
gold and silver that he would glue on to
his face
fortunately Tycho didn't need his nose
to continue his astronomical work he
kept studying the night sky and creating
all sorts of instruments including a
building sized quadrant for measuring
the angles of stars
after months of careful observation
Tycho discovered a new star in the
constellation Cassiopeia the publication
of this discovery granted him Rockstar
status and offers of scientific
positions all over Europe wanting to
keep him at home the King of Denmark
offered to give Tycho his own personal
Island with a state-of-the-art
Observatory called irani berg and
costing about 1% of Denmark's entire
budget this Observatory was more of a
castle containing formal gardens rooms
for family staff and visiting royalty
and an underground section just for all
the giant instruments
tygo also built a paper mill and
printing press for publishing his papers
and a lab for studying alchemy and since
no Castle would be complete without
entertainment Tycho employed a
clairvoyant dwarf named Jabba's court
jester Tycho lived on his Island
studying and partying for about 20 years
but after falling out with the new
Danish king
he took up an invitation from the Holy
Roman Emperor to become the official
Imperial astronomer in Prague
there he met another famous astronomer
Johannes Kepler who became his assistant
while Kepler's work interested him Tycho
was protective of his data and the two
often got into heated arguments in 1601
Tycho attended a formal banquet where he
drank quite a lot but was too polite to
leave the table to relieve himself
deciding to tough it out instead this
proved to be a bad idea as he quickly
developed a bladder infection and died a
few days later but over 400 years after
his death Tycho still had a few
surprises up his sleeve when his body
was exhumed and studied in 2010 the
legendary golden silver nose was nowhere
to be found
with chemical traces suggesting that he
wore a more casual brass nose instead
Tycho's moustache hair was also found to
contain unusually high levels of toxic
mercury was it from a medicine used to
treat his bladder infection a residue
from his alchemy experiments or did his
quarrelsome co-worker Johannes Keplar
poisoned him to acquire his data we may
never know but the next time you think
scientists lead waring lives dig a
little deeper a fascinating story may be
just beyond the tip of your nose
you